[Musique]
Noriel Roubini, bonsoir.
Vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Tout d'abord, c'est un plaisir et un
honneur d'être ici avec vous.
J'ai entendu parler de votre programme
qui est très populaire, donc c'est bien
d'être à Paris,
une de mes villes favorites au monde. Je
suis économiste.
Je suis né à Istanbul en Turquie.
Ma famille est une famille juive
originaire de l'Iran.
Quand j'ai eu 1 an, nous sommes repartis
à Tan. À l'âge de 3 ans, nous avons
émigré à Tel Aviv en Israël. Et à l'âge
de 4 ans, nous avons émigré vers Milan
en Italie où nous nous sommes installés.
J'ai grandi là-bas.
Je suis allé à l'école,
j'ai commencé mes études universitaires,
ma licence à Boconi et puis en 93, je
suis allé aux États-Unis pour mon
doctorat en économie à l'université de
Harvard.
Puis j'étais professeur à l'université
de Yale pendant 7 ans. Et puis en 95, je
suis allé à l'université de New York.
Je suis enseignant là depuis cette
époque, mais à un moment j'ai commencé à
être impliqué aussi dans les politiques
économiques. J'ai passé 2 ans à
Washington à la Maison Blanche et au
département du trésor lorsque Clinton
était président et je suis revenu à
l'université et
j'ai commencé à faire de la de la vie
économique, être consultant économique
en 2000200 et je suis surtout connu pour
être un des rares économistes qui ont
prévu la grande crise économique de
2007-2009
et d'où j'ai ce surnom de docte Doom
Cassandre en quelque sorte et j'ai été
impliqué dans euh en tant que
présentateur, en tant que conférencier
euh
donner des avis économiques. Mon dernier
livre vient d'être publié en France. Il
s'appelle Méga menace
publié chez Buch Chastel et comment
survivre à ces menaces aussi. Et je
passe la moitié de mon temps à voyager à
travers le monde et à rendre
compréhensible
ce monde très incompréhensible.
Je voulais vous remercier d'être venu
parce que vous faites partie de
de ce petit nombre de personnes qui ont
changé ma vie, qui m'ont appris à avoir
des yeux dans le dos et avoir un prisme
de lecture à 360°
pour anticiper les menaces. Et c'est un
réel plaisir pour moi de vous avoir ce
soir. C'est comme mon petit cadeau de
Noël. Je vais essayer de faire partager
ça à notre communauté. On va creuser le
sujet des menaces, de l'anticipation, de
la prospective. Ma première question va
avoir comme sujet
pourquoi les gens ne veulent pas voir,
ne veulent pas entendre quand des
menaces arrivent ? Est-ce qu'on attaque
tout le temps le messager ou est-ce que
c'est simplement de la cécité ou du déni
?
Bien question excellente question et
importante.
Il y a quelque chose probablement
en l'humanité
pour tenter d'éviter de faire face à la
réalité. Éviter de s'occuper de choses
qui pourraient aller de travers. Parce
que si vous vous en occupez, il faudrait
se préparer, faudrait agir. Et ces
actions coûtent cher en temps et en
argent.
en effort
et les gens vivent dans l'espoir que
quelque chose va se produire
peut-être une force extérieure comme
Dieu viendra les sauver ou qu'un
dirigeant
se lèvera et fera tout ce qu'il faut
pour éviter les crises
ou une révolution technologique
ou un coup de chance qui va éviter tout
cela.
Donc autant que faire ce peu, on essaie
de d'envoyer la balle plus loin. Parfois
il y a un une menace et on met la tête
dans le sable comme les autruches pour
tenter de pas avir le problème. Et quand
des gens comme moi
avertissent
des menaces ou alors ils vous disent que
vous êtes cassandre ou alors
ou quand je fais sonner l'alarme, ils
sont comme des zombies. Ils veulent
retourner au sommeil donc ils appuyent
sur le bouton arrêt de la sonnerie de
leur réveil.
Et puis voilà, on continue à marcher en
étant endormi sans être au fait de ce
qui se produit et en allant tout droit
vers le désastre.
Avant de développer
des questions concernant quelles sont
les menaces, je veux vous poser la
question est-ce que pour vous les
politiques, les politiques occidentales,
les hommes politiques, les femmes
politiques
sont prêts, ont la réelle perception des
menaces et ont-ils la capacité de
résoudre des choses ? Est-ce que vous
pouvez nous développer votre perception
du politique et les menaces sur
lesquelles auxquelles on va être obligé
de faire face ?
Ça dépend bien entendu des politiciens.
Certains d'entre eux sont plus au fait
de ces menaces, conscients de ces
menaces, d'autres les ignorent.
qu'il soit conscient ou pas, les
politiciens dans les pays démocrates
démocratiques doivent être réellu. Et
donc, par exemple, parmi tous ces
menaces que je décris dans mes livres,
chacune de ces menaces a des solutions.
Mais ces solutions impliquent des
coûtes, des sacrifices au court terme
pour un bénéfice qui arrivera à moyen ou
à long terme. Et si vous faites quelque
chose d'impopulaire, le risque est que
vous ne serez pas réélu.
Un exemple, le
le le chancelier Schredder qui était un
démocrate social, un socio-démocrate qui
voulait faire des
choses pour que l'Allemagne soit plus
compétitive, mais il a perdu les
élections parce que ces réformes ont été
très impopulaires.
Un exemple plus récent,
le président français Emmanuel Macron
suggère ou propose une réforme des
retraites qui est très impopulaire à
gauche, les syndicats, les travailleurs,
impopulaire aussi à droite, Le Pen et
d'autres et ses électeurs. Et c'est un
dilemme parce que s'il l'a fait passer
cette réforme,
il va être impopulaire. Ça va être par
exemple par décret où il y aura des
manifestations qui le rendront encore
plus impopulaires et les chance pour que
Le Pen soit élu en 2027 va augmenter.
D'un autre côté, s'il ne fait pas ses
réformes, les gens vont dire "Et ben,
on vous a élu pour une campagne pour des
réformes, mais qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait toutes ces années ?" Et il
deviendra impopulaire à cause de ça
aussi. et
tout représentant de son parti où les
forces modérées perdront les élections
en 2027.
Même dans des pays non démocratiques, je
crois que c'est difficile. Les gens
disent les régimes autocrates peuvent
faire des vrais choix. Non, c'est pas le
cas parce que même dans des régimes
autocratiques comme la Chine, il faut
être sensible aux opinions publiques
premièrement. Deuxièmement, il faut
faire des décisions difficiles qui
coûteront cher à court terme. Parfois,
les autocrates vivent dans une bulle.
Poutine vitle.
Il ne se rend pas compte des risques
parce que personne n'ose lui dire Chijin
Ping aussi vit dans une bulle parce que
personne n'ose lui dire que l'empereur
est nu. Votre politique ne fonctionne
pas. Et donc les autocrates aussi
prennent des décisions horribles.
Winston Churchill a dit justement que la
démocratie est le pire des systèmes
politiques mis à part tous les autres.
Et c'est vrai, je crois que
ce sont les difficultés des démocraties
libérales. En d tout cela, c'est le
meilleur système de gouvernance que tous
les autres systèmes autocratiques. Les
systèmes autocratiques font des grosses
erreurs, deviennent agressives quand il
y a des problèmes domestiques. On trouve
toujours des bqu émissaires, des menaces
imaginaires
et souvent les dictateurs vont faire la
guerre. Poutine l'a fait, les Argentins
l'ont fait, il y a beaucoup d'autres
exemples de la sorte.
Pour vous, les les 10 menaces que les
politiques et leur population vont être
obligés de faire face à quel prix
et à quelle échéance de temps ?
Celle qui va arriver tout de suite
maintenant, c'est quoi ? crise de la
dette, la crise géopolitique, la crise
alimentaire, la crise des dettes
souveraines, la crise des banques
centrales qui relève les taux, la la
l'insoutenabilité des dettes,
le réchauffement climatique.
C'est intéressant parce que j'ai écrit
ce livre sur la façon dont le monde peut
évoluer dans les 10 à 20 années à venir.
Et certaines de ces menaces sont plus
lentes à venir, d'autres sont plus
imminentes,
mais même celles qui sont plus éloignées
dans l'avenir. Je peux vous donner
beaucoup d'exemples. Comment chacun
chacune de ces menaces se matérialise
aujourd'hui.
Pas à 5 ou 10 ans d'aujourd'hui. Il y a
10 exemples pour ces 10 menaces. Bien
sûr, à court terme, il y a l'inflation,
il y a la récession,
ce qu'on appelle la stagflation, le
mélange de l'inflation et de la
récession.
C'est très clair pour les économies
avancées en Europe, aux États-Unis.
Il y a la menace de la dette qui sera
insoutenable alors que les banques
centrales montent les taux d'intérêt.
C'est aussi des menace à court terme,
mais par exemple le risque géopolitique,
les tensions internationales, le risque
de guerre entre les grandes puissances,
c'est quelque chose qui peut se
produire. C'est plus la guerre froide
entre les États-Unis et un certain
nombre de puissances révisionnistes qui
défit le système économique, social et
monétaire,
le l'ordre militaire mondial que les
États-Unis,
les Européens et l'Occident ont créé.
Ces puissances révisionnistes sont la
Chine, la Russie, l'Iran, la Corée du
Nord et même le Pakistan.
et ses alliés. Mais aujourd'hui, c'est
pas simplement une guerre froide. On a
une guerre chaude entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine.
C'est
une guerre d'homme de paille entre la
Russie et et l'Occident.
Sous certaines conditions, cette guerre
pourrait devenir non conventionnelle.
La Russie pourrait utiliser des
outils tactiques nucléaires en Ukraine
et ça pourrait impliquer aussi l'OTAN.
Donc c'est une menace imminente. C'est
pas à 10 ans d'aujourd'hui.
Je viens de passer 10 jours en Israël
avant de venir en Europe. Et il est
clair que l'Iran est sur le seuil
devenir un état nucléaire et Israël et
les États-Unis devront prendre des
décisions dures. Est-ce qu'il faut
frapper l'Iran ou pas ? Il faut faire
l'équilibre des bénéfices
et des pertes dans ce genre.
Et il y a aussi un baril de poudre et
les tensions entre sunnites et chiit. Et
au Liban par exemple, en Syrie, il y a
ces luttes en Irak, en Libye, au Yémen
et les choses peuvent suivre une
escalade. Et en Asie, cette guerre
froide entre les États-Unis et la Chine
devient
moins froide.
Et les dirigeants de la marine
américaine ont fait une déclaration sur
la Financial Times à la une en disant
que les risques que la Chine puisse
envahir Taiïwan sont élevés. Pas à 5 ou
à 10 ans d'aujourd'hui. Ils ont dit que
ça pourrait se produire
avant l'an 2024. C'était en octobre de
l'an dernier. Donc avant 2024, ça veut
dire 2023. Ben, on y est en 2023.
Je ne dis pas, je ne prétends pas que
cette guerre entre les États-Unis et la
Chine va se produire cette année. Mais
cette dépression régionale et ces
risques de guerre entre des grandes
puissances, chacune d'entre elles ayant
des armes nucléaires et l'Iran y arrive
aussi. C'est un risque qui est un
nouveau risque qui n'existait pas
précédemment. Moi, j'ai grandi dans les
années 50, 60 70
et je m'étais jamais inquiété de guerre
entre les grandes puissances ou d'un
hiver nucléaire parce que Nixon était
parti en Chine. C'était l'époque de la
détente entre les États-Unis et l'Union
soviétique. Et les risques de guerre
nucléaire entre ces rivaux
armé de d'armes nucléaires n'était plus
à zéro mais était très bas. Pour la
première fois aujourd'hui, depuis très
longtemps, il faut s'inquiéter d'une
guerre entre grande puissance et une
guerre qui passerait
une guerre avec des armes
conventionnelles pourrait commencer et
et pourrait déborder aussi vers le
nucléaire.
Donc
le changement climatique à moyen et long
terme, les pandémies,
la guerre entre des grandes puissance ou
l'effet de l'intelligence artificielle,
de la robotique, de l'automatisation,
ces choses se produisent déjà
aujourd'hui et comparé à l'inflation et
à la stackflation,
c'est beaucoup plus lent comme menace.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me décrire ce
qu'il faudrait faire
après le constat, par exemple, sur le
réchauffement climatique ? Est-ce que
les populations sont prêtes à accueillir
des pays à risque, exposés plus
rapidement au réchauffement climatique ?
Est-ce que l'immigration pourrait sauver
l'économie ? Est-ce que il faut
continuer la croissance ? Est-ce que les
politiques
ont cette capacité à faire passer ce
qu'il faudrait faire ? Où ou on s
sont-ils conscients de tout ça ? Vous
avez des eu des rapports avec François
Hollande, avec Emmanuel Macron ? Est-ce
que vous les avez senti avec les choses
de façon est-ce qu'ils sont conscients
de tout ça ou est-ce qu'ils survolent
les choses
?
Et bien des hommes politiques différents
à divers degrés sont conscients des
problèmes. Le problème c'est que
nous sommes tous inquiets du changement
climatique et c'est un des plus gros
risques parce que ça peut littéralement
détruire le globe, la planète au cours
des décennies à venir. Trouver des
solutions est difficile pour beaucoup et
de raisons différentes. Il y en a
plusieurs.
Pourquoi les gens ne font pas les bonnes
choses ? La première de ces raisons,
c'est que dans beaucoup de pays, à
commencer par les États-Unis, une partie
de la population ne croit même pas dans
le changement climatique dû aux humains.
Lorsque les républicains sont au
pouvoir, ils ne font rien et parfois ils
sont au pouvoir
et ils peuvent revenir au pouvoir en
2024.
Deuxème problème,
c'est que il y a un problème, un conflit
intergénérationnel.
Moi, j'ai 64 ans. Si je vis encore 30
ans, j'aurais beaucoup de chance. Mais
quelqu'un de jeune né aujourd'hui a une
expérience de vie de 100 ans. Donc
pendant ces 100 années, ils vont devoir
traiter du changement climatique. Mais
les jeunes ne votent pas. Les vieux
votent et même les jeunes
disent que bon à l'avenir un un miracle
se produira, la technologie résoudra ça.
Donc ils sont pas prêts à changer leur
style de vie, même les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui réduire leur empreintte
carbone. Si on était tous végétariens,
un/4 des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre vient de l'agriculture et de de
l'élevage des animaux. Et autre partie,
il faudrait isoler totalement nos
domiciles, mettre des panneaux solaires.
Et combien d'entre nous sont prêts euh
dans leurs armoires des dizaines ou des
centaines de t-shirts ou de vêtements
qu'on ne porte qu'une fois ? On consomme
trop. Il y a ce conflit aussi entre
jeune et vieux. 3è problème
mondialement, si un pays fait tout le
travail et tous les efforts pour réduire
ses émissions de gaz effici à zéro, mais
personne d'autre ne le fait, bah il y a
aucun bénéfice à ça. Les émissions sont
mondiales et eux, ils en payent le prix.
Et coordonner 200 pays, c'est très
difficile.
C'est vraiment ce qu'on appelle le
l'autostoop, les autostoppeurs hein qui
font rien et les qui profitent des
autres. Et il y a un un conflit entre
riche et pauvre.
les marchés émergents, la Chine, les
autres, on leur demande de d'arrêter
leurs émissions de gaz à effet de ser
comme nous on le fait. Mais ces pays-là
disent "Attendez, c'est vous qui avez
créé ce problème. Pendant 200 ans de
votre histoire d'industrialisation, 90 %
de tous les
euh euh les les émissions passées, ben
c'est à cause de vous les gars." Donc
c'est vrai que le nouveau flux de
d'émission vient principalement de la
Chine, de l'Indien et des marchés
émergents. Et ces gens-là disent
"Attendez, c'est vous qui avez euh créé
le problème. Nous, on veut pas rester
euh pauvre. On va accroître nos
émissions de gaz à effet de ser pendant
20 ans, puis après on en rediscutera.
À moins que vous nous subventionniez
et les subventions sont estimées à au
moins des milliards, des centaines, des
milliers de milliards de dollars.
Et le Congrès américain vient de voter
une loi où donne à quatre marchés
émergents 4 milliards. Ça veut dire quoi
? C'est rien.
Ça va pas le faire. Le 5è problème,
c'est que il y a un conflit entre
les États-Unis et la Chine, guerre
froide. Ils sont pas d'accord sur la
pandémie,
ils sont pas d'accord sur la sécurité
mondiale, ils sont pas d'accord sur le
libre échange, ils sont pas d'accord sur
vivre et résoudre les crises financières
et économiques. Ils sont pas d'accord
sur le changement climatique
et cetera et cetera.
Le 6e problème
pour
réussir à arriver au but de des accords
de Paris, la taxe carbone devrait être
de 200 dollars la tonne de carbone.
Aujourd'hui, la taxe moyenne est de 2
dollars la tonne, moins aux États-Unis,
un petit peu plus en Europe. Quel est
l'homme politique qui va accroire la
taxe carbone par un facteur de 100 de 2
à 200 dollars ? personne, c'est
politiquement impossible, ils feront
l'inverse. Maintenant, les prix du
pétrole sont élevés et bien tous les
politiciens est en train de diminuer les
impôts sur le pétrole pour réduire
l'inflation et réduire les coûts pour
les gens. Il y avait
une transition de de l'énergie fossile
vers l'énergie renouvelable ne se fera
pas parce qu'il faut qu'il y a une
incitation monétaire et de ces toutes
les solutions
arrivé à zéro carbone et arriver mais ça
ça amènera à une croissance zéro aussi
en 2020 au pire de la récession des 60
dernières années les émissions de gaz
effet de serre
sont à 9 % maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus bien plus que c'était pendant la
période du Covid. Donc maintenant c'est
avec la technologie actuelle c'est
impossible de diminuer les gaz à effet
de serre. L'autre solution c'est de
faire monter les la température au-delà
de 2 et 3 degrés. Et le lutter cela, ça
va vous coûter des milliards et des
milliards de dollars. À New York, il y a
eu le cyclone Sandy. On a voulu protéger
Manhattan. Il y avait une proposition de
construire un mur au thé de Manattan et
tout le monde a dit "Ah non, ce serait
une prison." Maintenant, on a dit "On
veut mettre des levées de terre près de
du pont de Veratzano." Ça va compter 125
milliards de dollars cette levée de
terre. Ça va prendre 25 ans et ça sera
obsolescant une fois que ça sera
construit. Ça peut ne pas fonctionner.
Ça ne fonctionnera que lorsque les eaux
monteront à cause d'une d'un cyclone ou
d'une tempête, mais ça ne protègera pas
la montée des eaux. Et alors
si vous protégez Manathan et alors le
reste et New Jersey et les autres, c'est
la cité, la ville la plus riche du
monde. Ça sera protégé. Et tout le reste
des gens vivent sur des zones côtières.
Donc l'adaptation est trop euh chère et
ça c'est véritablement par exemple, on
parlait de de science-fiction, d'envoyer
des particules dans l'atmosphère pour
cacher le soleil, ça marche pas. C'est
l'écart entre ce que l'on veut faire et
la réalité. C'est pour ça qu'il y a
tellement de verdissement, de green
washing, de souhait, de verdissement.
Il y a tellement de d'histoires qui ne
sont que des conneries et il y a la
l'inflation verte,
par exemple, produire des véhicules
verts et cetera, bah il faut du lithium,
il faut du cobalt, il faut du zinc, du
cobalt, il faut beaucoup d'énergie pour
les produire et donc il y a une
inflation verte en fait qui va faire que
la production de ces véhicules verts est
très chè. Voilà, ce sont les impôts
auxquels il faut parler. Pour la plupart
des gens, on dit non, si vous faites que
du solaire ou des trucs comme ça, il y
aura on évitera le changement
climatique. Mais non, c'est une des méga
menaces et il y a beaucoup d'obstacles
sur la route de cette de cette solution.
La chaîne de transmission entre votre
cerveau, le cerveau des politiques, le
cerveau de la population, c'est le
journalisme.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le
journalisme ou le journaliste
est suffisamment affuté pour comprendre
ce type de menace et suffisamment
courageux pour écrire les bons papiers ?
Je prends l'exemple, vous vous annonciez
la crise de 2008 et les journalistes
avec l'aide de différents économistes
vous sont tombés dessus.
C'est parce qu'ils ne comprenaient pas.
C'est parce qu'ils étaient motivés pour
vous faire terre.
C'était quoi ? Est-ce que les
journalistes sont suffisamment affutés
par rapport au risques ?
Ça dépend, il y a des bons médias
suffisamment élaborés qui peuvent parler
des risques et en parler, les décrire.
D'autres qui ne le sont pas, qui ne sont
pas aussi qualifiés pour le faire.
Mais dans le cas, disons des de la crise
mondiale financière,
il faut comprendre les motivations
qui ont mené à cette bulle.
Les gens qui voulaient acheter une
maison pouvaient acheter avec très peu
de fond. Ils pouvaient emprunter
énormément
en hypothéquant leur maison et les prix
mont. Ils étaient contents. Les
politiciens étaient contents parce que
les gens pouvaient dépenser plus de leur
revenus et dans la bulle de leur
appartement. Les banques prêtent
l'argent en faisant des hypothèques et
en gagnant là-dessus. Les banques
d'investissement monétisaient toutes ces
hypothèques et faisait de l'argent avec
ça. Les agences de notation notaient ses
avoirs toxiques
euh et faisait de l'argent avec ça.
Les évaluateurs des maisons faisaient de
l'argent les évaluant très de façon très
élevée et les assureurs faisaient de
l'argent également. Donc il y avait une
monétisation, une chaîne de monétisation
où tout le monde était gagnant. Tout le
monde gagnait de l'argent.
Les euh propriétaires étaient contents,
Wall Street était content, les
politiciens étaient contents et tout le
monde vivait dans une bulle. Et dans
cette bulle, on commence à croire des
choses qui sont impossibles, que les
prix des appartements peuvent monter de
20 % chaque année pour toujours. Et un
jour, c'est quoi la bulle ? Un jour, la
bulle éclate.
Donc les masses ont leur propre
désillusion.
Les politiciens vivent de ces illusions
là et les institutions financières font
de l'argent sur ces illusions aussi.
Donc parfois, on vit dans une bulle, on
vit dans des illusions jusqu'à ce que la
bulle éclate et le rêve devient
cauchemar. Ça se produit à nouveau et à
nouveau et à nouveau. L'histoire de
toutes les crises financières, c'est
tromper les masses des investisseurs qui
euh font grossir la la bulle et en
bénéficie. Et voilà, et elle finit par
exploser.
En anticipant tous ces risques,
En anticipant tous ces risques, est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va se terminer
dans un bain ? sanglant
en terme d'émeute, d'instabilité
sociale, de tension entre les minorités.
Est-ce que vous sentez
ce petit murmure de d'émeutes ?
certainement une des conséquences
de toutes ces menaces
et de cette instabilité par-dessus tout,
c'est le risque
de malaise social de toutes sortes.
soit des malaises dans le monde du
travail, de la violence entre la gauche
et la droite,
la montée des extrémismes des parties de
droite et de gauche,
des régimes populistes et autoritaires
qui deviendront agressifs parce que
s'ils ont un problème interne, ils vont
trouver des beaux émissaires et ils vont
faire la guerre comme la Russie le fait
avec l'Ukraine.
Oui, il y a une montée dans l'inégalité.
On voit les classes moyennes et les
classes ouvrières.
On voit que les jeunes n'ont pas
d'opportunités et d'occasions
économiques comme par le passé. Les
nouvelles générations seront plus
pauvres que celles de leurs parents et
ça va faire des réactions contre la
démocratie libérale. Il y a des partis
de gauche et de droite autoritaires qui
sont plus populaires aujourd'hui. Il y a
Poutine en Russie, il y a Erdogan en
Turquie, il y a Orban en Hongrie,
il y a Kazinski en Kazinski en Pologne.
Méloni et son parti néofasciste qui est
arrivé au pouvoir en Italie.
Les démocrates Suèdes Suédois ont dû
s'allier au néonazie pour monter une
coalition même dans cette Suède
tolérante. Et en Grande-Bretagne, il y a
le phénomène du Brexit.
Et ils ont changé de premier ministre en
6 mois, trois fois. En France, il y a
toujours de la démocratie. Mais un des
risques, c'est qu'en 2027, Le Pen arrive
au pouvoir. Au États-Unis, il y a
l'élection de Donald Trump et sa rage
contre les élites et qui prétend être
populiste, qui s'occupe d'école blanc.
Ça c'est à droite. À gauche et bien en
Amérique latine ben il y a les cas de
l'Argentine, Venezuela avec les
populistes de gauche,
les populistes de droite sont de gauche
sont arrivés au pouvoir au Mexique,
au Pérou, au Chili,
en Colombie.
Au Brésil, il y avait le choix entre un
populiste de gauche et un populiste de
droite. Bolsonaro et Loua, heureusement,
c'est Loula. Et Bolsonaro était
autoritaire. Il a tenté un coup contre
Loula de la même chose qu'il a fait qui
a eu cette tentative de coup d'état
contre le Capital il y a 2 ans. Et le
plus grand autoritaire de tous, je sais
pas s'il est à gauche ou à droite, c'est
bien sûr Shijin Pin en Chine qui n'est
plus secrétaire général du parti. Il est
président, c'est même plus président. Il
est l'empereur de Chine, il décide de
tout. Il a plus de leadership collectif
et il peut faire de grosses erreurs
comme tous les autoritériens le font.
Comme tous les autoritaires le font.
Tous les dirigeants autoritaires
finissent par faire des grosses erreurs.
Il y a cette tendance à travers le monde
entier, vers le populisme, vers
l'autoritarisme, vers l'agressivité,
vers d'autres à l'extérieur de vos pays.
Et ça mène aussi à des problèmes
internes, sociaux parce que il y a un
malaise économique. Oui, de façon
différente. dans différents pays, ça
peut mener à une variété de différentes
formes de problèmes sociaux si ce n'est
pas de la violence sociale.
Est-ce que vous pensez Est-ce que vous
pensez que les I let you reboot your
plug, you've got it? Yes. Just on your
right shoulder. Yes, youve got it.
Je vais attendre que vous mz Voilà,
parfait.
Est-ce est-ce que vous pensez que d'ici
les 6 à 12 prochains mois, les banques
centrales vont retourner leur vestes
concernant l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt ? Parce que la soutenabilité
des dettes d'État vont devenir
insoutenables. Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'ils vont continuer ce phénomène de
cavalerie financière où ils vont serrer
la vis jusqu'au bout ?
Et bien, il y a deux façons de voir les
choses en ce qui concerne ce que vont
faire les banques centrales.
une vision, c'est que l'inflation est
arrivée au top et qu'elle va baisser et
donc ils peuvent monter les taux
d'intérêt plus lentement
avec une
petite récession avec quelques
trimestres de croissance négative
et après la récession
il y aura suffisamment de
baisse
et au milieu de l'année et la récession
sera terminée, l'inflation sera terminée
et les banques centrales vont baisser
les taux d'intérêt et on pourra
recommencer la croissance
dans la seconde partie de l'année.
Première moitié difficile pour
l'économie et le marché. La deuxième
moitié,
il sera meilleur pour le marché et
l'économie.
C'est ce que disent les banques
centrales dans la plupart des économies,
que ce soit Wall Street et la City de
Londres.
Moi, ma vision est différente. Ma vision
est que l'inflation
va rester beaucoup plus élevée
et va baisser mais pas
descendre rapidement vers 2 %. Donc la
question c'est pas si l'inflation est au
top. Elle est arrivée au top. Mais
est-ce qu'elle va passer de 10 à 5,6 ?
Oui, c'est facile. Mais de 5 6 à 2, ça
va être très difficile.
Les prix vont être difficiles.
Le le l'assouplissement quantitatif sera
difficile. C'est des tendances
inflationnistes.
L'inflation des salaires va être très
important parce que les marchés du
travail sont très serrés. Le chômage est
faible.
Euh le vieillissement de la population,
les gens qui partent à la retraite plus
tôt,
les gens quittent leur travail.
Réduction des forces de travail, des
taux de participation de beaucoup de
gens, les restrictions de la de
l'immigration,
les tensions sociales des travailleurs
qui disent "Nos salaires diminuent, on
va lutter, on va se battre.
et les politiques
des euh gouvernements sont en fait en
faveur des employés, en faveur des
syndicats pour éviter
les manifestations.
Donc ça ne signifie pas qu'il y aura une
grosse inflation des
salaires, ça sera 5 ou 6 % et ça
maintiendra l'inflation au-delà de 2 %.
Et dans la dans les services, dans le
secteur des services, le coût de
production plus important, c'est le
travail effectivement.
Et si l'inflation du coût du travail
sera élevée, et bien les coûts du
service seront élevés. Ces facteurs
implique une inflation qui va diminuer
mais n'arrivera pas à 2 %. Donc la
banque centrale ne peuvent pas
lutter contre l'inflation. Donc il
faudrait qu'il mettent les taux
d'intérêt à 4 %. Mais si vous allez
au-delà de 4 % il y a deux choses qui
vont arriver. Il va y avoir un
atterrissage difficile de l'économie.
plus vous levez vous élevez les taux
d'intérêt, la récession sera plus longue
et plus dure que une une
inflation à long terme mais à bas bruit.
Mais s'il y a une inflation, le coûte
pour les travailleurs, pour les
entreprises, pour l'immobilier, pour les
entreprises, ça va devenir plus cher.
Tout va être plus cher. Le coût des
hypothèques, le coût des crédits, le
coût des cartes de crédit, des emprunts
personnels, des emprunts d'entreprise,
des obligations d'entreprise, des des
des euh tous ces gens qui ont des
dettes, c'est c'est le service de la
dette va augmenter. au cours des 20
années à venir euh les taux de de
remboursement
va augmenter mais au cours des 20
dernières années, il y avait pas
d'inflation, il y avait des taux
négatifs et donc il y a ce qu'on appelle
le le l'assouplissement quantitatif ou
l'assouplissement du crédit, c'était
très bas. Il y a 2 ans, 18 trillions de
dollars de dettes publiques
en Europe et au Japon.
avait un taux d'intérêt négatif.
Les hypothèques au Danemark avaient un
rendement négatif. Certaines entreprises
pouvaient être empruntées
à des taux négatifs parce que à cette
époque-là, l'inflation était à moins de
2 % et on on se battait contre
l'inflation trop basse par des
stimulations
financières. Maintenant, c'est fini.
l'inflation augmente, les taux d'intérêt
sont remontés et ces phénomènes euh
qu'on appelait ce que j'appelle moi les
zombies qui sont euh qui ne sont qu'on
ne peut pas euh
qu'on ne peut pas qui sont insolvables
et ben ils vont être ils vont aller en
banquroute et cette récession va
augmenter et les revenus vont baisser,
les salaires vont baisser aussi et le
taux de dette va devenir plus élevé,
insoutenable. créer plus d'instabilité.
Donc il un cercle vicieux dans
l'économie. Il y a une contraction
économique instabilissée et une fin une
une contraction financière aussi. Donc
il y aura pas simplement de l'inflation,
pas simplement de la récession, il y
aura de la stagflation.
Il y aura une dette une crise de dette
stagflationniste
autour de ces problèmes tous ensemble.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qui est un choc volcaire,
le mécanisme du choc volcaire ? Et
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer à notre
communauté les répercussions que ça
pourrait avoir sur la population active
?
Dans les années 1970,
il y avait deux chocs pétroliers.
l'un qui suivait la guerre du Kipour
dans les années 70. Tous les pays
pétroliers ont triplé leur coût du
pétrole ou multiplié par 10 même et
l'inflation a tripler. Et dans les
années suivantes, il y a eu un choc
deuxème choc pétrolier dans la
fourniture de pétrole et il y a eu une
récession, une staflation, l'inflation
qui était hors contrôle. Il y a eu euh
une montée des prix parce que chaque
fois que ces chocs se produisaient, la
réaction des banques centrales a été pas
de monter les taux de d'intérêt pour
arrêter l'inflation et l'inflation est
arrivée hors contrôle. Ce n'est qu'en 79
que l'inflation est devenue un tel
problème que le président Carter a
choisi comme directeur de la fête Paul
Folker. Il a dit à Folker, "Fais ce
qu'il faut pour lutter contre
l'inflation."
il a poussé les taux d'intérêt vers 20 %
parce que l'inflation était au-dessus de
10 %. Ça a mené à une récession
extrêmement dure dans les années 8082.
C'était un une récession à à double cône
et à ce moment-là, les salaires sont ont
diminué. Il n'y avait plus suffisamment
de pouvoir pour que les syndicats et les
ouvriers puissent faire monter les
salaires et l'inflation est descendue.
Mais ça a coûté
beaucoup de récession pendant plus de 2
ans même à cette époque-là.
Le problème aujourd'hui est le suivant.
Tout comme dans les années 70, on a des
chocs de fourniture négatifs.
L'impact du Covid sur la production des
biens, la chaîne de fourniture, les la
fourniture de d'emploi, l'impact de
l'invasion des Russes en Ukraine sur la
fourniture d'énergie.
Mais
dans les années 70 1970,
il y avait de l'inflation de la
stackflation.
Il n'y avait pas une crise de la dette
dans les économies avancées parce que
les taux de dette étaient bas 100 % du
PIB. Aujourd'hui, on est à 400 % du PIB.
Quatre fois plus
après la crise financière mondiale, il y
a eu problème de la dette. trop de
dettes pour l'immobilier, les
hypothèques et les prêts bancaires,
mais il y a eu un choc de la demande,
pas un choc de l'offre. Il y a eu un un
credit crunch et une fois qu'il y a eu
la déflation, on a pu euh alléger les
politiques monétaires et fiscales et le
crédit pour aider l'économie réelle
parce que il y avait peu d'inflation, il
y avait pas suffisamment d'inflation.
Aujourd'hui, on est avec le pire des
années 70 parce que on a les chocs
négatifs et la stacflation, mais on a
quatre fois plus de dettes que dans les
années 70 et on entre dans une
récession,
on ne coupe pas les taux d'intérêt mais
on augmente les taux d'intérêt parce
qu'il y a de l'inflation.
Donc il y a un problème d'inflation,
on a un problème de stackflation et on a
problème de dette tous les trois
ensemble, une dette excessive.
Si vous ne voulez pas vous occuper du
problème de la dette en montant les
impôts ou en coupant les dépenses, la
solution c'est que il y a une taxe sur
l'inflation.
Vous monétisez le déficit, vous créez de
l'inflation et l'inflation
quand elle n'est pas attendue va réduire
la valeur réelle de la dette nominale de
longue durée.
À un taux d'intérêt fixe, la valeur rle
cette dette est réduite par l'inflation.
Effectivement, c'est comme une taxe en
fait sur le capital, une taxe sur euh
l'épargne et les créditeur et transfère
cet argent vers les gens qui sont euh
qui ont emprunté vers les emprunteurs en
raison de cette texte de cette taxe sur
l'inflation. C'est une des solutions de
ce problème. Et donc quand on aura une
euh inflation
plus importante parce que nous sommes
dans un piège, si on lève suffisamment
les taux,
vous allez créer une crise de la dette.
Face à ce risque économique
et ce risque de croche financier, les
banques centrales
parlent durement
mais elles ne vont pas tenir, elles vont
devenir des colombes, elles seront plus
des des faucons parce que elles ne
pourront pas faire face à ce croch et
donc face à ces taux d'inflation plus
élevé, je crois que c'est ce qui va se
produire. C'est la façon dont on pourra
le traiter, c'est que
il faut trouver le point de moindre
résistance pour pouvoir sortir de cette
de de de ce problème.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait que
Ben Bernit reçu l'équivalent du prix
Nobel d'économie ? Est-ce que c'était le
prix l'équivalent du prix Nobel
d'économie pour Boomer ? Parce que Ben
Bernan a protégé les classes d'âge les
plus âgées, les classes d'âge d'heure
entiers. Est-ce qu'il a reçu ce prix
parce qu'il a sauvé l'économie mondiale
ou est-ce qu'il a simplement repoussé le
problème sous le tapis ? Mais il s'est
vu gratifier de ce prix parce que
c'est dans l'air du temps.
Il a reçu ce prix parce que c'était un
universitaire de la grande dépression
et durant la grande dépression,
le marché des actions de 29 est devenu
dépressif parce qu'on a permis à
beaucoup d'agriculteurs, beaucoup
d'entreprises, beaucoup de banques à des
millions de s'effondrer. Beaucoup
d'entre eux étaient illiquides. Il
n'avaient pas suffisamment de liquidité.
Ils étaient pas en banqoute, mais comme
ils ne pouvaient pas euh avoir le crédit
nécessaire, il y a eu un problème de
liquidité et c'est devenu un problème
d'insolubilité. Et là, ils sont devenus
en banqurroute. Et ça a commencé à un
choc qui a créé la grande dépression. Il
y a eu un
une un effondrement de la demande
lorsque la grande crise s'est produite.
La leçon était il faut faire plus de de
d'assouplissement de crédit pour éviter
que cette récession devienne une
dépression 2.0.
Il y a une logique à faire cela
pour éviter cette banroute de certaines
parties du secteur public et privé.
Mais l'addition qui est passée de 100 %
du PIB dans les années 70 à 400 % du PIB
de dette, c'est que chaque fois qu'il y
a une bulle,
on ne l'arrête pas et les gens
empruntent trop et la bulle mène à plus
de dette. Et lorsque la bulle explose,
on dit "Oh là là, il y a un risque
systémique, il y aura un risque
financière, une dépression. Et donc on
assouplit le crédit. Donc le coûte de
l'emprunt est plus facile et ça mène un
nouvel une nouvelle bulle. On narrête
pas la bulle au bon moment et on essaie
de protéger des gens des effets d'un
effondrément.
Et cette réaction asymétrique implique
plus de bulles, plus euh d'effets
levier, plus de dettes. Et après, on
sauve les gens à la mauvaise époque
qui
donc si vous êtes protégé et assuré,
vous prendrez plus de crédit qu'il n'en
faut. Donc c'est un biais de
construction de dette excessive. et Ben
Bernard qui a écrit des articles sur la
raison pour laquelle il faudrait pas
essayer de d'essayer de faire exploser
la bulle au bon moment. Il a dit que ce
serait trop dangereux. Il a dit quand la
bulle devient trop grosse et bien
qu'elle explose. À ce moment-là,
faudrait protéger le système d'un d'un
effondrément totale comme durant la
grande dépression. Mais ne pas faire les
les choses à la bonne époque et de
s'occuper de la bulle qu'elle explose,
ça crée ce biais qui crée plus de
bulles, plus de dettes, plus
d'hypothèques pourries. Et ça c'est il a
appris quelques leçons de la grande
dépression de 29, mais il a pas appris
les leçons de ce que ça signifie d'avoir
trop de dettes et de perdre de faire
trop de perte ensuite.
Quel regard vous portez sur Christine
Lagarde ? Quand Christine Lagarde répond
à un présentateur de télévision
anglaise,
la question était quand est-ce que nous
allons rembourser les dettes ? Et
Christine Lagarde lui répond en temps
voulu, en temps voulu,
est-ce que c'est parce qu'il y a pas de
solution ? Est-ce que c'est pour ne pas
créer la panique que Christine nous
répond ce type de de réponse ? Est-ce
que Christine marche sur le fil du
rasoir ? Est-ce que Christine est une
très bonne communiquante ou est-ce que
Christine n'a rien dans les mains comme
on dit au poker et que c'est du bluff
pour maintenir le système
calme ?
Je l'ai rencontré à plusieurs occasions.
C'est une
politicienne extrêmement avisée. Il a
beaucoup d'expérience. Elle était
ministre des finances en France.
Elle a eu elle était à la tête du
fondaire international et maintenant
elle est à la tête de la Banque centrale
européenne. Ce n'est pas une économiste
de formation, c'est une juriste, mais
elle a pris beaucoup de l'économie
et des liens entre l'économie et la
politique.
Elle est quelqu'un de très haute
qualité. Elle est un politicienne de
très haute qualité. Et comme toute
politicien de haute qualité, elle est
soumise à des contraintes.
Les politiciens ne sont pas idiots. Ils
sont pas méchants, ils sont pas abruti,
ils veulent pas euh endommager les
choses. Le problème de la banque
centrale, c'est que l'inflation
est montée énormément dans la zone euro
en partie en raison de ces chocs de
fourniture négatif, mais en raison des
stimulis
de crédit monétaire était trop long
après la COVID. C'était une erreur
politique de faire ça. Toutefois,
maintenant
vous avez un dilemme.
Si vous montez les taux d'intérêt pour
lutter contre l'inflation, vous allez
causer une récession et une récession
grave.
Mais si vous ne montez pas les taux
d'intérêt suffisamment pour lutter
contre l'inflation, vous risquez d'avoir
un
un désancrage
et les prix vont monter en spirale comme
dans les années 70
que vous le fassiez que vous le fassiez
pas. Mais il y a une couche
additionnelle maintenant de stress.
Quand vous montez les taux d'intérêt,
comme je l'ai dit, beaucoup de
gouvernements de la zone euro, certaines
banques, certains gouvernements,
certaines entreprises,
certaines
certains foyers ont beaucoup de dettes
et beaucoup vont devenir insolubles et
vont aller à la banquoute et ça peut
heurter, ça peut endommager la véritable
économie
et donc il y a beaucoup de risques
d'instabilité.
Bah, la BCE a créé ce nouvel instrument,
le TPI,
un instrument de protection
transverse qui dit que si l'écart, le
spread de tout membre de la zone euro
s'accroit trop, qui risque de créer un
risque de dette pour le gouvernemental,
autant que ce accroissement du spread
est dû à la panique
dans la dynamique des marchés et que ce
n'est pas justifié par les fondamentaux
économiques. À ce moment-là, la BCE
pourrait acheter des obligations de ce
pays et éviter une risque une crise de
se produire. Mais en pratique, la raison
pour laquelle les écarts peuvent se
croître, c'est pas simplement parce que
les gens sont irrationnel dans le
marché, mais parce que il y a des
politiques fiscales qui sont trop
laxistes et un manque de réforme
économique. Regardez ce qui se passe au
Royaume-Uni
lorsque les stimulis fiscaux ont été
punis par le marché avec le le
l'accroissement des écarts de crédit et
que la livre sterling s'est effondré. La
BCE peut voir que les pays font les
bonnes choses mais en raison des
investisseurs irrationnels
font des
des mauvaises choses. Mais à ce
moment-là, la BCE peut ne pas pouvoir
agir et il y aura une crise de la dette.
Et c'est une couche additionnelle
d'insécurité pour les décisions prises
par la BCE. C'est pas facile, hein.
Est-ce que la solution ce ne serait pas
de répudier la dette comme ce qui est
écrit dans la Constitution américaine ?
Est-ce que les États ne devraient pas
répudier la dette sur autre chose ? On
entend beaucoup ça. Certains
économistes, certains hommes politiques,
certaines personnes disent "Répud dette
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cet
argument de de répudiation de la dette ?
Quand il y a une dette excessive, à
chaque fois,
il y a potentiellement beaucoup de
solutions. Chacune d'entre elles a des
avantages et certains coûtent. Bien sûr,
la meilleure solution pour la dette,
problème de la dette, c'est une
croissance économique très élevée parce
que c'est un ratio entre la dette et des
revenus. Si vos revenus s'accroissent,
votre dette devient plus soutenable.
le le ratio de dette par rapport au
revenus diminue. Quand la dette est
élevée, la croissance diminue et quand
la croissance diminue, la le taux de
dette devient plus élevé et on tombe
dans un cercle vicieux. Certaines
personnes disent "Si votre dette est
excessive,
et bien économisez, dépensez moins et à
ce moment-là serrez-vous la ceinture."
Au niveau individuel, ça fonctionne.
J'ai trop de dette, je dépense moins,
j'économise, je peux réduire ma dette.
Mais si tout le monde dans l'économie
fait la même chose, dépense moins,
économise plus, et ben la récession
s'aggrave.
Et quand la récession s'aggrave, les
revenus baissent et le taux euh de dette
ça croix. C'est ce que Keins, Kanes
l'économiste appelait
le le le paradoxe le paradoxe de de
l'économie.
Si vous économisez et si vous
investissez, si vous empruntez dans une
devise extérieure, vous n'avez pas
d'autre choix. que euh de ne pas repayer
votre dette
rchelonner peut-être ou c'est ce que
font les pays pauvres. Mais dans les
économies avancées comme l'Europe et les
États-Unis qui empreintent dans leur
propre euh devise, vous pouvez réduire
le nominal de votre dette en ayant une
inflation surprise parce que l'inflation
signifie que vos coûts d'emprunt en
terme réel sont réduits et le la valeur
réelle de votre dette diminue. Donc une
inflation inattendue est un défaut
formel, mais vous êtes en train de taxer
les emprunteurs et euh mais c'est pas un
défaut formel, c'est passé par une taxe
sur l'inflation. Une autre euh solution,
c'est vous forcez les banques à garder
les dettes des gouvernements. Et si la
demande euh s'accroit,
et bien la dette décroit. Mais c'est un
impôt sur euh les sur les investisseurs.
Si vous voulez, vous pouvez aussi taxer
les gens qui sont les plus riches, mais
c'est une forme de taxation des
créditeurs et des gens qui ont de
l'épargne et de la d'amener l'argent
vers les emprunteurs. le défaut, la
monétisation, l'inflation, la
capitalisation, la taxation,
l'expropriation,
la répression fiscale ou tout simplement
dire queon ne repaye pas. Mais c'est
tout ça autour de la même idée. Quand il
y a trop de dettes, et ben faut choisir
votre poison, choisir quel est le poison
qui est le moins dangereux pour vous. Et
ça, ça dépend de différentes variables.
On va essayer de poser une colle à notre
interprète préféré.
Est-ce que vous connais la connaissez la
mitydratisation
?
OK, c'était une colle. OK, je vais poser
une autre question.
Je sais pas si prendre un petit peu de
poison chaque jour
va vous protéger contre le poison, vous
immunisera
ou si c'est une mort lente. Je crois que
ça serait plutôt une mort lente plutôt
que
c'est comme
faire bouillir une grenouille à petit
feu mais la température monte mais
finalement la grenouille va mourir parce
qu'elle sera bouillie. C'est ça hein la
dette le remboursement échelonné.
Quand vous avez vu Jeanette Tiélène
s'excuser publiquement du fait qu'elle
n'ait pas vu l'inflation venir,
ça vous a fait rire ? vous a vous avez
pas été surpris de son incapacité à à
prévoir l'inflation ? Qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé ?
C'était pas simplement Jeanette Hélène.
La Fed,
la BCE, toutes les économies avancées,
les politiciens
n'ont pas vu l'inflation arriver.
D'un côté euh
ils ont fait une erreur. D'un l'autre
côté beaucoup d'économistes et des gens
de Wall Street ont fait la même erreur.
Pendant 20 ans, le problème des
économies avancées, c'était pas une
inflation élevée, c'était cette cible
des 2 % et l'inflation était de moins de
2 %, parfois proche de zéro.
après la la crise financière mondiale,
il y a une déflation et le début de la
crise de la COVID, il y a une déflation
parce qu'il y a une baisse de la demande
qui était plus importante que la la
baisse de l'offre.
Et pendant la crise financière,
on avait pas suffisamment
de stimulis monétaires et fiscaux et la
reprise était anémique. La croissance a
repris mais très faiblement.
Le taux de chômage est resté élevé et
n'est descendu que faiblement.
Donc lorsque le choc de la COVID s'est
produit, tout le monde à droite ou à
gauche a dit "On a fait une erreur
pendant la crise financière. On avait
pas suffisamment de stimulis fiscaux.
Maintenant parce que le choc a l'air
beaucoup plus gros et ben on va faire un
stimulus massif."
Le problème c'était que une fois que le
stimulus était
hors de taille deux ou trois fois plus
que le PIB, ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont
fait 10 ans auparavant. Et deuxièmement,
la crise financière mondiale était une
crise euh qui a duré 2 ou 3 ans alors
que le choc de la COVID en terme de
récession
a duré de février 2020 jusqu'au mois de
mai, juin. C'était une récession très
profonde
de de elle a duré deux trimestres et
avec la réouverture de l'économie
lorsqu'on a aplati la courbe et avec
le stimulus fiscal et de crédit, la
croissance est repartie très vite. Le
stimulus est devenu trop fort, trop long
et trop excessif d'un côté.
Et deuxièmement,
à court terme, la demande a baissé plus
que l'offre, mais la demande a repris
grâce au stimulus. Les gens ne sont pas
rendus compte parce que ils n'avaient
pas vu les chocs négatifs de l'offre
depuis les années 70 que le Coved était
aussi un choc d'offre négatif qui
réduisait les services et qui réduisait
aussi l'offre d'emploi qui créait
des des des goules et d'étranglement. Ça
a été le premier choc. Et puis en 2022
l'année dernière il y a eu un autre choc
de l'offre.
Il y a eu cette invasion de l'Ukraine
par les Russes qui a accru les prix de
l'énergie, du gaz naturel, des aliments,
des engrais et des métaux industriels.
Et il y a eu un troisème choc, c'était
la politique du zéro Covid en Chine qui
a ajouté une couche additionnelle de
d'étranglement.
Donc, il y a eu une combinaison de
mauvaise politiques,
de euh d'assouplissement de crédit et
d'assoupment financière et aussi les
trois agrégats euh de de fourniture de
d'offres négatifs. Mais il faut aussi
comprendre pourquoi ils ont fait ces
erreurs les politiciens.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a de
l'éthique sur les marchés financiers ?
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que les
marchés financiers sont devenus
incontrôlables avec des gens
mégaloman,
corrompus,
venu
au mains de où le leur seul objectif,
c'est de faire de l'argent à tout prix
pour se prendre des stock option, se
prendre des dividendes, se prendre des
bonus au détriment
de la population réellement
travaillante. Est-ce que les marchés
financiers, il y a de l'éthique ? Et
est-ce que les marchés financiers sont
réellement là pour financer l'économie
réelle ?
les marchés financiers
ont des fonctions positives,
de prendre des épargnes, de l'épargne et
de la louer dans des bons
investissements, dans des projets
d'investissement, financer des choses
qui sont utiles comme des hypothèques
pour que vous puissiez acheter votre
appartement, votre maison
ou des prêts personnels pour amortir vos
chocs de
ou permettre à des entreprises de
croître.
Mais lorsque l'emprunt devient excessif,
lorsque les crédits de lorsque les
normes de crédit deviennent trop
laxistes et que vous pouvez avoir un
effet levier trop élevé, vous prenez
trop de risqu et bien vous faites une
bulle,
la valeur des actifs devient plus
élevée. Vous pouvez utiliser ces actifs
comme collatéral pour
prendre plus de prêt. Les gens prennent
trop de risques, il y a de la fraude,
ils deviennent arrogants et ça amène à
un boom, à une bulle et finalement à une
explosion et un crash. Et vous avez
raison, les êtres humains seront
toujours cupides. Certains d'entre eux,
spécialement dans les marchés
financiers. C'est pas les marchés
financiers seulement. Au cours des
dernières années, une nouvelle
génération, une jeune génération de
jeunes Z qui n'avaient pas de formation,
qui n'avit pas de revenu. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ? Du trading ? Ils achètent
des mini actions, ils achètent de la des
cryptoonnaies en croyant qu'ils peuvent
devenir riches en 24 heures. Personne ne
devient riche en 24 heures. Peut-être un
sur des millions. Tous les autres
perdent leur culottes. C'est pas
simplement un groupe de spéculateurs de
Wall Street et de gens cupides qui sont
le problème. Non, c'est de bout en bout.
Tout le monde joue avec l'argent et tout
le monde a ce type d'illusion et de
tromperie.
Le travail de la politique monétaire,
le travail des superviseurs et des
régulateurs du système monétaire serait
d'arrêter les bulles
avant qu'elles ne devienne trop grosse.
On peut monter les taux d'intérêt, on
peut contrôler mieux le crédit, on peut
limiter les effets leviers. Il y a toute
une gamme de politique de prudence pour
éviter des bulles de crédit qui crée des
bulles d'actifs. Le problème, c'est que
dans les bonnes époques, mettre en place
ces politiques est difficile.
Les politiciens et les emprunteurs se
plaignent en disant "Oh ouais, vous me
laissez pas investir, vous me laissez
pas emprunter et moi je le fais pour des
bonnes raisons cet empreinte."
Et les régulateurs sont capturés par
Wall Street, sont aux mains de Wall
Street. Parfois, les politiciens sont
corrompus et lorsqu'il y a une bulle, il
y a toujours une histoire qu'on raconte.
Pourquoi il y a une nouvelle technologie
révolutionnaire, l'internet,
les trains, les cryptonnaies qui
justifie l'investissement
et utiliser les effets leviers de cette
bulle. Ce sont des fantasmes et ça finit
par des larmes. Mais en pendant ce
temps-là, la bulle sort de tout contrôle
jusqu'à ce qu'elle explose et puis vient
la bulle suivante. Ce sont des cycles,
on pourrait les contrôler avec une
meilleure politique monétaire, des taux
d'intérêt plus élevés, un contrôle du
capital, un contrôle du crédit, des
réglementations prudentielles,
supervisation des banques, des systèmes
financiers.
réduire les dérivatifs toxiques, réduire
la financiérisation toxique et cetera,
mais on le fait pas.
Donc on passe par ces cycles encore et
encore.
On risque des on risque de voir la fin
bientôt quand même. Quel regard vous
vous portez sur les cryptos les
cryptomonnaies ? Quel regard vous portez
sur les derniers scandales de de
cryptoonnaie ? Est-ce que certains ont
raison de dire que c'est la solution ?
pour que les politiciens arrêtent de
faire de la dette pour faire de la
subordination de vote. Est-ce que les
cryptos
vous y croyez ? Est-ce que les cryptos
d'État vous y croyez à dosser sur des
matières premières réelles ?
Bah personnellement,
je suis sceptique. J'ai toujours été
sceptique des cryptoonnaies. Je les ai
critiqué.
en 2016-27 déjà et je suis resté sur ce
point de vue. Ce sont de la fraude, ce
sont des pyramides de Ponzi, ces
criminels, ce sont des bulles qui vont
finalement exploser.
Regardez, l'année dernière,
au cours des 12 derniers mois,
même le Bitcoin a perdu 80 % de sa
valeur de 69000 à 16.
Euh l'Etheréum a perdu plus de 80 % de
sa valeur. Les autres top 10 ont perdu
de 80 à 90 % de leur valeur et bien sûr
des dizaines de milliers
de ces introductions de d'offres de euh
de bitcoins ou de monnaie
ont été des fraudes. Les gens l'ont
utilisé pour acheter des Lamborghini,
des propriétés dans les Caraïbes. 99 %
c'est de la fraude pure et simple. Les
appeler des cryptomonnaies,
c'est en fait c'est une erreur
d'appellation. C'est pas de la monnaie,
c'est pas des devises, c'est pas une
unité de compte parce que il y a rien
qui n'est valorisé en Bitcoin.
Ils ne sont pas échelonnables en terme
de paiement parce que avec les bitcoins,
vous pouvez faire 7 transactions par
seconde.
Avec la Visa, vous pouvez faire 50
transactions à la seconde.
C'est pas véritablement une valeur
stable parce que la valeur du Bitcoin
peut monter de 10 20 % en 24 heures.
même les cryptoconférences n'acceptent
pas les paiements en Bitcoin parce que
leur marge de profit de la conférence
pourrait être effacé en quelques heures.
Ce c'est pas un numéraire. Un numéraire
simple, ça veut dire qu'il y a une unité
de compte que je puisse comparer le prix
du pain par opposé par opposition au
prix du de la viande par exemple.
Donc on a besoin d'un numéraire simple
unique dans le monde de la tokenisation
où il y a des milliers de jeton.
Quand j'ai besoin d'un d'un jeton Pepsi
pour acheter un Pepsi Cola et un un
jeton Coca pour acheter du Coca-Cola, je
peux plus vous dire quel est leur prix
relatif entre Coca-Cola et Pepsi Cola,
entre le pain et la viande. comme euh
revenez revenir à à par exemple
euh vous sa souvenez-vous par exemple de
ce dessin animé les pierres à feu hein
avec des échanges eux ils avaient ils
utilisaient eux un numéraire unique ils
utilisaient des coquillages et avec ces
coquillages il pouvaient dire quel est
le prix de la viande par rapport au prix
du
euh de la viande. les appeler euh de la
monnaie, c'est pas de la monnaie, ça n'a
aucun sens.
Ce n'est même pas des actifs.
Vous savez, il y a il y a un revenu sur
les actifs.
Les actions vous donnent des dividendes.
Les euh les brands, les obligations vous
donnent des des coupons, des taux
d'intérêts.
Des emprunts d'entreprise vous donnent
des taux d'intérêt, des intérêts.
L'immobilier vous donne des loyers.
Vous avez des services en en en louant
votre maison.
Le pétrole, l'énergie, le la nourriture,
ça vous donne des services. Mais ces
garslà, ils n'ont aucun revenu.
L'or n'a pas de revenu, mais ça a une
utilité. Par exemple,
vous utilisez par exemple l'or, l'argent
pour créer des joyaux, pour créer des
bijoux. Mais prenez le Bitcoin, ça n'a
pas de revenu,
ça n'a pas d'utilisation dans
l'industrie, ça n'a aucune utilité.
Personne ne porte un un
un Bitcoin. Ben personne enfin, il y a
quelqu'un qui porte des Bitcoin, mais ça
ne signifie rien. C'est pas très
populaire hein, de porter des bitcoin,
hein. Porter des joyaux en Bitcoin. On
peut pas valoriser le Bitcoin parce que
il y a soit un un flux d'utilisation,
un flux monétaire pour qu'on puisse
avoir une véritable valeur et qu'on
puisse dire quelle est la valeur du
Bitcoin, il est impossible de les
valoriser. C'est pour ça que les gens
disent que le Bitcoin ça va être 1
million et d'autres disent ça va valoir
zéro. Ma vision c'est que la valeur
fondamentale du Bitcoin c'est zéro. même
c'est négatif, c'est même pas zéro
parce que le Bitcoin a
des externalités
tellement négative, ça utilise tellement
d'énergie à miner,
beaucoup plus que le
en fait plus que le PIB de l'Argentine
ou de Pays-Bas.
Si on impliquait, si on incluait le prix
de la création d'un Bitcoin, sa valeur
serait très négative.
Donc ce ne sont pas des devises, ce ne
sont pas des actifs,
ce sont c'est de la fraude, c'est des
escrocs, c'est des criminels, c'est des
fraudeurs, ce sont des gens qui font de
l'évasion fiscale, des terroristes et
d'autres qui ont des activités illégales
comme des trafics d'êtres humains. C'est
le seul la seule utilisation des Bitcoin
et de ces monnaies pour des activités
illégales. C'est la criminalité absolue
et la SBF
c'est pas l'exception,
c'est la règle. C'est tous des pyramides
de Ponzi, c'est tous des criminels. Ils
devraient tous finir en prison.
Not all criminals.
Almost.
J'ai j'ai une question concernant je
vais vous poser une question internet
d'ailleurs.
Une question de l'ours.
Aujourd'hui,
quel est le marché le plus risqué aux
États-Unis ? L'immobilier ou les crédits
à la consommation ?
Les deux sont en fait reliés
parce que
ce qui s produit aux États-Unis et dans
les pays anglo-saxons, c'est que pendant
un temps long, les revenus des gens ne
montaient pas suffisamment par rapport
à leurs
attentes de consommation. Comme ils
disent, les Américains ne pouvaient pas
être au niveau des voisins des Jones.
Chaque personne se comparer aux voisins.
Il disait "Ah, ils ont l'air plus riche.
Leur bagnole est plus cher que la nôtre.
Leur maison est plus riche que la
nôtre." Quelle était la solution qui a
été donnée dans les pays anglo-saxons ?
C'est ce qu'on appelle la
démocratisation de la finance.
Je vais vous permettre d'avoir autant de
cartes de crédit que vous voulez
emprunter pour acheter votre voiture. Je
vais vous laisser emprunter pour vos
préétudiants. Empruntez autant que vous
voulez pour acheter une maison et mettre
très peu d'actifs.
Et lorsque la valeur de votre maison
montera parce que tout le monde
emprunte, vous pouvez emprunter encore
plus. C'est le home equity withdraw.
Alors, comme le taux, comme la valeur de
votre maison augmente, je peux prendre
encore plus de crédit parce que euh
cette ce crédit que je vais prendre va
dépasser mon revenu. Et en fait, votre
maison était comme une un un un dab, un
distributeur automatique de billets.
Donc, le problème des hypothèques et le
problème de la consommation sont les
deux côtés de la même pièce. Vous
utilisez votre maison comme un dab et
vous l'utilisez pour tirer de l'argent
pour consommer au-delà de vos revenus.
Et donc c'était aussi un problème de
consommation. Et quand le problème des
hypothèques a a explosé et bien la bulle
de la consommation a explosé aussi et il
y a de l'inégalité.
les
le taux de
l'économie réelle n'est pas monté assez
suffisamment et les coûts des services
qui a augmenté le coûte de l'éducation a
augmenté aussi et quand les gens sont
désespérés ils financent en emprunt plus
et à ce momentl vous créez une bulle et
lorsque vous créez une facilité de
crédit et ben à ce momentlà la bulle
augmente encore plus protectionnisme
économique
En principe, je suis en faveur de du
libre échange, de la globalisation, de
la migration, du capital, du travail,
de
du commerce, des services et des biens.
Les pays qui l'intègrent bien ont
réussi. Par exemple, vous prenez
les 27 pays de l'Union européenne. S'il
y avait pas eu d'Union européenne, il y
aurait des petites économie, des petits
marchés et il pourrai pas grandir ou
grossir assez rapidement, aussi
rapidement que s'il y avait ce marché
unique. Donc
la plupart des pays de l'Eurozone ont
bénéficié de la mondialisation. Regardez
la Chine ou l'Inde, ils sont tellement
pauvres et soudain, ils deviennent moins
pauvres quand ils se sont ouverts à
l'économie mondiale. Ils ont rejoint les
marqués les marchés mondiaux et le libre
échange. Regardez
la Corée du Nord, la Corée du Sud. Au
début, à la fin de la Corée de la guerre
des Corée, les la Corée du Nord avait
beaucoup plus que la Corée du Sud. Mais
la Corée du Sud a investi beaucoup dans
son économie, dans l'éducation. Mais les
la Corée du Nord, les gens sont en train
de mourir de faim parce qu'elle est pas
ouverte et la Corée du Sud fait bien.
Bien sûr, la globalisation, la migration
amène à des gagnants et à des perdants.
Si vous avez un pays
par exemple à faible valeur ajouté
contre par exemple des pays à haute
valeur ajoutée et bien votre
pays
peut être mis en danger parce que il
peut être submergé par des produits de
faible coût venant des pays à très
faible valeur ajoutée. Mais il aurait
fallu aider à ceux qui ont perdu leur
travail en étant formés à nouveau pour
avoir de nouveaux emplois. Mais on ne
l'a pas fait.
On a fait
suffisamment de croissance pour pouvoir
imposer ceux qui ont gagné beaucoup pour
former et donner de l'argent à ceux qui
ont perdu. Mais on ne l'a pas fait.
Les gagnants ont tu encore une plus
grosse part du gâteau alors que ceux qui
avaient perdu qui étaient restés sur le
bord de la route n'ont jamais été aidés
et c'était le début des réactions des
coles bleues et contre la mondialisation
et contre l'immigration.
Donc c'est une bonne idée la
mondialisation mais il faut s'occuper de
la distribution, des effets de
distribution. Sans ça, vous pouvez euh
avoir une grande partie de votre pays
qui ira beaucoup plus mal que euh
précédemment.
On a vu récemment
Exon être exposé dans la presse pour
montrer sa préconnaissance ou son
anticipation du réchauffement climatique
depuis 1970
environ. Vous avez suivi cette cette
histoire là à peu près ?
Euh est-ce que on va voir euh les grands
énergéticiens, les grands pétroliers se
faire attaquer comme les industries du
tabac par des classes action ? Et est-ce
que les répercussions sur le prix de
l'action de ces mêmes énergéticiens
auront des des conséquences par exemple
dans le portefeuille de certains fonds
de pension censés garantir la retraite
des fonctionnaires américains ? Quel
quelles aurait les répercussions de la
dévaluation massive d à des classes
action contre les énergéticiens et quel
quels auraient les répercussions de ces
baisses de prix de ces dévaluations
d'actifs dans le portefeuille de
certains fonds de pension américains ?
Il y a une possibilité qu'il y ait des
actions groupées contre les
énergéticiens de la même qui a eu des
actions contre les sociétés de tabac.
C'est une menace potentielle sur leurs
bénéfices
et leurs actifs, mais n savons pas pour
l'instant si
ces actions en justice réussiraient et
quelles seraient
les pénalités qu'ils auraient à payer.
Je dirais que à court terme
ce que ces entreprises craignent plus
c'est puisque les prix de l'énergie sont
élevés, les bénéfices de ces
énergéticiens ont cru énormément et dans
beaucoup de pays, il y a cette vision
que on devrait imposer ces profits
exceptionnels parce que ils sont
excessifs
et il faudrait prendre ces
ces est revenu vers les
les individus ou les entreprises qui
sont impacté affecté par c
prix de l'énergie.
Mais
les contrearguments, c'est que
dans un monde où les prix de l'énergie
sont élevés parce qu'il y a pas
suffisamment de fourniture d'énergie, si
vous les imposez
et toutes les entreprises sont
sous-investis
elles sous-investissent dans les
énergies fossiles, c'est il y aura moins
de production et finalement le coût de
l'énergie deviendra plus élevé.
Trouver la bonne réaction, la bonne
réponse n'est pas aisée. C'est facile de
taper sur les grands pétroliers, ben on
va vous imposer plus. Mais il faut voir
quelles seront les conséquences
possibles. Je suis plus en faveur de du
traitement du changement climatique. Et
parce qu'on est inquiet des émissions
qui viennent qui viennent des énergies
fossiles, on tape sur euh les
fourniturs, les fournisseurs les
fournisseurs de pétrole. On dit aux gens
de sous-investir dans les énergies
fossiles, d'aller vers les
renouvelables. Et on dit aux banques et
bien ne n'investissez pas dans les
compagnies
si elles n'investissent pas dans les
renouvelables. Toute la pression
les actionnaires, la société civile, les
banques implique que au cours des 5 10
dernières années, les grands pétroliers,
les privés en tout cas ont sous-investi
dans des nouvelles capacités, des
nouveaux champs pétrolifères,
l'énergie fossile. Donc la fourniture
d'énergie fossile décroit mais la
fourniture d'énergie renouvelable ne
croit pas à la vitesse suffisante pour
compenser la baisse de capacité des
énergies fossiles. Maintenant on a un
problème structurel de manque de
fourniture d'énergie.
Même avant
l'invasion russe en Ukraine, le Brent
c'est le prix du pétrole Brent était
près de 100 dollars le baril même avant.
Donc c'est pas simplement l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine qui a causé
l'accroissement des prix de l'énergie.
en partie aussi c'était en raison de
sous-investissement dans les capacités
d'énergie fossile en raison du fait
qu'on leur tapait sur la tête
et donc ce sont certains des effets euh
qui sont pas voulus.
Vous connaissez la COP
[Musique]
un président de la COP issu du monde du
pétrole,
c'est normal, c'est pas normal pour
l'année prochaine ça. Ça c'est une bonne
initiative, c'est un message passé au
producteur de pétrole. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ?
Écoutez, la COPE à Glasgow
et la COPE à Charmelcher,
c'était des échecs.
Pas simplement parce que
les présidents de certains compagnies
patrou avaient trop d'influence,
mais la plupart des entreprises
ont des plans net zéro. Mais les plans
net zé
sont faites par leur département de
communication. Ils sont pas écrits par
les dirigeants politiques et par les
scientifiques. Tout le monde prétend
aller vers zéro émission. Ça veut rien
dire. Mais c'est comme ça qu'il sauvent
la face. Ils font quelques petites
petits changements cosmétiques
pour réduire de l'énergie mais ils ne
réduisent pas véritablement leur
empreint de carbone. Tout ça c'est du
verdissement hein. C'est des vœux pieux.
Même même si tous les engagements des
dernières COPES devaient être tenus et
c'est un grand si hein parce que ni les
États-Unis ni l'Europe ne font ce qu'ils
disent. Mais même si les engagements
actuels étaient tenus, est-ce qu'on aura
un une montée de température ? Ça sera
pas de 1,5, ça sera pas de 2°gr.
Le niveau actuel, ça sera une
trajectoire de 2,4°.
Même si on fait tout ce qu'on a promis.
Et si on fait tout ce qu'on a promis à
la fin de ce siècle, ça sera + 3° C.
1,5 c'est mal. 2 c'est horrible. 3 c'est
une catastrophe
et on va vers plus 3 degrés. Faut être
réaliste
et tout le monde est en train de faire
du verdissement.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du forum de
Davos ?
Le forum de Davos,
j'y suis allé plusieurs années, pas
chaque année. C'est un des forums, un
des forums parmi beaucoup d'autres où il
y a des dirigeants mondiaux qui se
réunissent et ils débattent de problèmes
économiques mondiaux. Est-ce qu'ils
résolvent des problèmes ? Non.
Il y a d'autres forums aussi, toute
conférence à travers le monde. On parle,
on débat, on essaie de trouver des
solutions, mais ce sont pas des forums
de prise de décision. Les décisions sont
prises au niveau national ou
international dans d'autres forums comme
le FMI ou la Banque mondiale et cetera.
et bien des gens qui se réunissent
et qui se parlent plutôt que de se faire
la guerre. C'est une bonne idée.
C'est une bonne idée
avoir des leaders mondiaux, économiques,
politiques, religieux, culturel et
cetera. C'est une bonne idée. Bien sûr,
au cours des dernières décennies
euh on était sensible au aux problèmes
sociaux. Donc, il y avait des
entrepreneurs sociaux.
Il y avait beaucoup aussi
d'organisations gouvernementales, d'ONG
et d'autres qui traitait des droits
sociaux. Il tentaiit d'être plus
représentatif
avec un spectre plus large de vision sur
tous ces problèmes.
C'est un bon forum, il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui sont aussi bons où les gens
se réunissent et débattent.
C'est plus qu'un atelier de discussion
plutôt qu'un atelier de décision. C'est
utile, mais je ne crois pas que tout
individu isolé ou tout forum, toute
organisation
puisse résoudre des problèmes mondiaux
sur la pandémie mondiale,
le l'OMS
n'a pas réussi à résoudre le problème
sur des problèmes de commerce. On va
vers le protectionnisme, des
globalisation
et l'Organisation mondiale du travail a
des pouvoirs limités.
Les Nations Unies ont des pouvoirs
limités en implémentant la sécurité
mondiale.
La Banque mondiale, le FMI ont un bon
travail mais ont des pouvoirs limités.
On n'a pas des institutions de
gouvernance mondiale qui ont
suffisamment de pouvoir pour appliquer
des décisions mondiales, faire des
règles mondiales. Et maintenant, il y a
une réaction contre la globalisation,
contre la mondialisation, contre les
organisations supranationales
parce qu'on dit que ils n'ont pas de
légitimité démocratique, que qu'ils font
fi des souverainetés nationales. On vit
dans un monde où les problèmes sont
mondiaux. le changement climatique, les
pandémies,
la sécurité mondiale, la sécurité
financière, la sécurité militaire,
l'impact de l'IA.
Donc pour des problèmes mondiaux, on a
besoin de gouvernance mondiale. On a
besoin de plus de gouvernance mondiale,
pas moins. Malheureusement, pour
l'instant, il y a
une réaction nationaliste. Comment
protéger mon pays, mes travailleurs,
ma maison et ça va plus vers le
protectionnisme. Mais vous savez,
mes impôts sur vos exportations et mes
importations réduisent vos exportations.
Et si vous prenez votre revanche, vos
prix vont réduire mes exportations vers
vous. Et si vous commencez une guerre
à croître les taux doués des deux côtés,
tout le monde est perdant et c'est
mondialement.
Donc bien sûr, la mondialisation du
commerce a un coûte, il faut s'en
occuper, il faut que ça soit soutenable,
faut que ça soit inclusif, faut que ça
donne de l'égalité.
Mais le protectionnisme c'est pas la
bonne solution.
Je vais vous lire une question
d'internet que je vois passer sous mes
yeux. On a commencé à y répondre mais je
vais vous la lire quand même.
Est-ce qu'il est possible d'estimer les
risques du changement climatique entre
parenthèses eau, perte de biodiversité,
maladie ? Fermez la parenthèse sur
l'économie globale ? Si c'est le cas,
n'est-ce pas un argument suffisant pour
convaincre n'importe quel économiste de
changer de paradigme ?
Bien, le coût du changement climatique
et la perte de la moitié de la diversité
biologique
parce que on a cette vision
anthropomorphique où tout est centré sur
l'homo sapiens et on se fiche
effectivement du bien-être animal et du
bien animal mal des plantes, elles
votent pas, les plantes votent pas, les
animaux votent pas. Mais endommager la
planète, détruire les les plantes et les
animaux, ça a un certain amendre
d'effets second qui ont un coûpt même
pour les êtres humains. Et détruire la
planète crée des dommages. Les cyclones,
les la montée des eaux de mer, des
inondations, des feux,
ça a un coût énorme pour les humains.
Sans parler des animaux.
Mais sans aucun doute, faire quelque
chose sur le changement climatique est
sujet à beaucoup de problèmes et de
contraintes politiques et économiques
qui nous empêch de faire les bonnes
choses.
Est-ce que vous voulez qu'on aborde un
point spécifique que vous avez écrit
dans votre livre Méga menace ? Est-ce
que vous avez un point en particulier
que vous voulez faire passer à notre
communauté ?
Et bien ce que je voudrais vous dire et
mettre l'accent sur quelque chose, nous
avons eu
75 années de paix relative, de progrès
et de prospérité,
disons après 1945
et nous avons cru que l'avenir serait
comme le passé récent et nous avons On
fait nos projections de cette
manière-là. Toutefois, je crois que
c'est une erreur pour plusieurs raisons.
Tout d'abord, même au cours de ces 75
années,
entre 1945
et jusqu'au début des années 80 était
très différent des 20 dernières années.
Et je veux vous décrire ainsi. Moi, je
suis assez vieux. Vous vous êtes plus
jeune que moi, Sky. Moi, j'ai 64 ans, je
suis né dans les années 50 et j'ai
grandi dans les années 60 70 au début
des années 80 entre le Moyen-Orient et
l'Europe avant d'arriver aux États-Unis.
Quand j'ai grandi,
je me suis jamais inquiété de la guerre
entre les grandes puissances et l'hiver
nucléaire.
Non, les problèmes de la Chine
connaissais pas. Je me suis jamais
occupé du changement climatique parce
qu'on en a jamais parlé. Je me suis
jamais inquiété de la pandémie.
J'entendais même pas le mot.
La dernière fois, c'éit en 1918, la
grippe espagnole.
Je me suis jamais inquiété de
l'intelligence artificielle qui
détruisait des des des des emplois des
emplois. Non, jamais. Ça existait pas.
Le même le mot n'existait pas.
L'intégration de l'Europe,
NAFTA,
l'hyperglobalisation
avec la Chine, la Russie, l'Inde, les
marchés émergents. On nen parlait pas à
cette époque-là.
Je me suis jamais occupé de la crise de
dette. Le taux de dette entre le taux le
ratio entre dette et PIB était très bas.
Je m'occupais jamais de la dette
implicite et
il y avait beaucoup de jeunes
travailleurs. Les impôts étaient payés
pour le bénéfice de gens plus âgés.
Aujourd'hui, c'est exactement l'inverse.
Je me suis jamais occupé de dépression.
Oui, c'est vrai, il y avait des cycles
économiques un peu de récession qui
étaient légers dans les années 70.
L'année 70, oui, il y avait une
stacflation mais ça a été suivi par 30
années de grande modération.
On n'avait pas de grande crise
financière qui allait du boom, de la
bulle et du crash. Non, il y avait le
contrôle des capitaux, il y avait des
répressions financières et il y avait
pas un des leviers toxiques de
financiarisation que l'on a aujourd'hui.
Les cycles économiques étaient stables
et finalement on vivait dans des
démocraties libérales. Oui, il y avait
centre gauche, centre droit qui était en
désaccord, mais il y avait pas de
polarisation extrême
qu'il y a aujourd'hui entre l'extrême
populiste de gauche et les extropulaires
de droite, populistes de droite qui se
tapent dessus. Dans comme aujourd'hui,
on a on a un risque de guerre entre les
superpuissances, de guerre nucléaire,
pas simplement une guerre commerciale.
Le changement climatique est une
catastrophe. Les pandémies se produisent
de plus en plus fréquemment. Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi il y en avait pas entre 1980 ?
Maintenant, on a on a le VIH Mars, le
SARS,
la grippe avière, le Zica, l'ébola, le
Covid-19
en très peu de temps parce qu'on détruit
l'habitat animal, ces animaux qui sont
qui ont les les les germes pathogènes et
bien ils sont en contact avec les
humains et les zones de transmission
sont beaucoup plus fréquentes. Donc on
aura des pandémies plus graves à
l'avenir. Maintenant on a le risque de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
détruire encore plus d'emplois avec des
inégalités permanentes, des du chômage
technologique.
Il y a la démondialisation du
protectionnisme des cycles économiques
plus violents, beaucoup plus explosifs.
la dette implicite qui vient des
personnes âgées, des régimes
autoritaires de gauche et de droite qui
arrivent au pouvoir.
Les 20 dernières années montrent
l'émergence de ces méga menaces qui
n'existait même pas dans les 40 années
précédentes, entre 45 et les années 80.
Un point supplémentaire,
la période entre avant 1945, il y a eu
35 années qui ressemblent à aujourd'hui.
En dépit de la première
ère de mondialisation,
on n' pas évité la Première Guerre
mondiale et puis après on a eu la grippe
espagnole et puis le crash de 29 et puis
le début de la grande dépression et puis
on a eu l'inflation.
l'hyperinflation, la déflation,
les guerres euh euh commerciales,
les crises financières,
les crises de la dette, les défauts,
chômage de 25 %
et puis ensuite les nazis nazis avec
Hitler sont arrivés au pouvoir en
Allemagne. Les fascistes avec Mussolini
sont arrivés au pouvoir en Italie.
Franco est arrivé au pouvoir en Espagne
et
les militaristes sont arrivés au pouvoir
au Japon et il y a eu la deuxième guerre
mondiale et on a eu la choa et seulement
après ça, on a créé ces grandes
institutions qui nous ont donné la paix
et la prospérité pendant un certain
temps et maintenant on a les méga
menaces.
Bon, ces années horribles entre 1914 et
1945 étaient horrible. Il y a quatre
méga menace qui n'existait pas à
l'époque et qui existe aujourd'hui. À
l'époque, il y avait pas à s'occuper du
changement climatique. C'était pas un
problème. On s'occupait pas de l'IA,
l'intelligence artificielle qui
détruisait les emplois. Ça existait pas
les ordinateurs. Il y avait pas à
s'occuper de la dette implicite des
gouvernements parce que la sécurité
sociale, les retraites venaient d'être
créé à peine et la plupart des gens
mouraient avant d'avoir leur premier
chèque de la retraite.
Aussi horrible que soit la première
guerre mondiale et la deuxième guerre
mondiale, c'était des guerres
conventionnelles.
Ce n'est qu'à la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale que c'était plutôt
heureusement les Américains plutôt que
les Nazis qui ont eu la bombe. Les
Américain ont utilisé la bombe sur
Hiroshima et Nagasaki pour arrêter et
terminer la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Cette fois, s'il y a un conflit entre
les superpuissances, cette guerre ne
sera pas guerre conventionnale.
Conventionnelle, ça va commencer
conventionnel, mais il peut rapidement
aboutir à une guerre nucléaire. Ça peut
mener à un hiers nucléaire pour
l'humanité comparé aux années 30 et 40.
Aujourd'hui, les choses avec ces méga
menaces, ces megamenaces n'existaient
même pas au cours de ces 30 horribles
années entre 1914 et 1945. On ne peut
pas croire que le progrès est assuré. On
ne peut pas mesurer l'avenir à l'ondre
du passé. On est comme des zombies. On
marche
en dormant vers l'avenir, on ne les
problèmes s'accroisent de plus en plus
tous les jours. Ils sont interconnectés
et à moins de changer. Ça sera pas
simplement la fin de nos emplois, de nos
payes. Ça pourrait être la fin de la
planète, la fin de l'humanité et la
destruction de notre propre espèce.
C'est le risque auquel on fait face
aujourd'hui. Je dis pas que ça va se
produire, mais il faut être conscient
des problèmes. Commencer à les corriger
individuellement, collectivement,
nationalement, internationalement. Et le
temps pour agir, c'est maintenant. On
perd du temps. Le temps pour agir, c'est
maintenant et on le fait pas. On va
arriver à la dystopie, l'instabilité, le
chaos, le désastre.
C'est mon message.
Psychologiquement parlant,
comment c'est une question plus
personnelle que je vais vous poser. Vous
êtes pas obligé d'y répondre. Quand vous
faites
un une prospective autour de toutes ces
menaces, psychologiquement parlant,
qu'est-ce que ça crée chez vous ? Est-ce
que vous dormez bien ? Est-ce que ça
vous honte de voir la passivité
intellectuelle des gens, des politiques,
des marchés financiers, des économistes,
de tout ce que vous voulez ? Comment
vous gérez cette pression
à force d'avoir autant de connaissance ?
On dit souvent heureux les simples
d'esprit aujourd'hui, j'ai compris.
Comment vous vous sentez vous
personnellement par rapport à toutes ces
méga menaces ?
Écoutez,
quand le Covid s'est produit,
beaucoup d'amis ont quitté New York.
Moi, je vis à New York. Ils sont allés à
Miami. Ils sont allés dans les Hampton,
dans les les collines du Hampton. Ils
sont allés dans le haut de d'état de New
York. Moi, j'ai passé toutes les
journées du Covid à New York. Je suis
même pas allé une fois à Miami ou dans
les Hampton au cours des 3 années qui
ont suivi. Juste que ça se soit terminé
parce que
il y a eu un confinement. J'aurais pu
être malade, j'aurais pu être à
l'hôpital, j'aurais pu mourir et puis il
y avait des manifestations,
il y avait effectivement il y a eu de la
violence, il y avait des émeutes, il y
avait du pillage.
La plupart des magasins dans mon
quartier ont été fermés avec du bois
parce que elles étaient pillées. Mais il
y a pas d'échappatoire, il faut y faire
face.
S'il y avait une autre s'il y a une
autre pandémie
euh vous savez, il y a beaucoup de gens
qui auraient un ground zero. Il va se
reproduire un ground zero. S'il y a une
guerre nucléaire, la première bombe
nucléaire va tomber sur New York,
Washington, Pékin et Moscou. Tout le
monde à New York va mourir.
Le changement climatique
accroit le niveau de la mer. La plupart
de Manathan, des quartiers de Madrid
sera sous sous les eaux. Il y aura
d'autres cyclones. Une bonne partie de
Manatan était
sous l'eau. Vous pouvez acheter une
grotte quelque part dans les collines.
Vous pouvez acheter quelque chose en
Nouvelle-Zélande mais la plupart de
l'humanité va va être tué. Moi, je
préfère être à New York, être engagé
socialement, politiquement à tenter de
résoudre ce problème pour que ça se
produise pas. Parce que si ça se
produit, je préférerais mourir comme
tout le monde plutôt que de m'échapper
quelque part. Donc voilà, la réalité
c'est que la façon de s'occuper de cela,
c'est de s'engager, d'en parler, de
prendre des actions et de vivre votre
vie telle qu'elle est plutôt que
d'essayer de vivre dans un monde de rêve
parce que ces rêves vont devenir des
cauchemars et on ne peut pas échapper à
la réalité.
que ce soit le Covid. Avant le Covid,
j'ai passé la moitié de mon temps à
voyager à travers le monde. J'avais pas
d'amis pour voir mes amis. Et euh en
fait là, j'ai pu apprendre à à à à faire
la cuisine. J'ai pu faire des dîners du
shabbat tous les vendredis soirs et
beaucoup de musiciens ne pouvaient plus
je pouvais plus entendre des musiciens
en direct. Et voilà, grâce à la
pandémie, j'ai pu écouter des gens, j'ai
pu parler avec mes amis et je n'ai pas
échappé à la ville et on a créé des
communautés. Donc si vous voulez euh
chaque problème a un bon côté, c'est
queon a des meilleures relations euh
amicales, on a moins d'anonymat,
des gens sont devenus plus solitaires,
plus anonymes. Moi, j'ai créé une
communauté d'amis et même au niveau
personnel, ça a été une occasion de
croissance, d'être plus d'avoir plus de
compassion et d'être plus conscient des
autres.
vos proches, vos amis euh quand on vous
a décrit comme le docteur Doom, celui
qui voyait tout en noir, celui qui a qui
a prédit les 15 dernières crises alors
qu'il y en avait 10, c'est comme ça que
certains économistes français vous
qualifient. Nuriel Rubini, c'est celui
qui anticipe 10 crises sur 5. Et
quand vos amis prennent conscience que
vous aviez raison, vous avez raison,
est-ce qu'ils se mettent en catatonie
émotionnelle, en catatonie
intellectuelle
ou est-ce qu'ils en demandent plus ?
Quel quel effet ça a sur eux de de
prendre conscience des choses ?
Mais je ne suis pas docteur Dom, je suis
pas Cassandre, je suis pas toujours plus
pessimiste. Il y a deux grands
événements cours de la dernière décennie
où j'étais beaucoup plus optimiste que
le consensus
en 2015.
2015,
le consensus sur Wall Street était que
le Grexite va se produire, que la Grèce
allait quitter la zone euro, tout Wall
Street, Colman Sax City et cetera. Tout
le monde disait le Grecit va se
produire. J'ai passé beaucoup de mois à
aller à Athè, à Berlin, à Paris et à
dire que dans ce jeu qui va faire peur à
l'autre entre la Grèce et la Troicka, la
Grèce avait pas un bon jeu en main et
devrait céder. et je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait 200 milliards de
dollars. C'était la carotte
ajoutée au bâton pour faire la réforme
et ça mènerait au fait qu'il resterait
dans la zone euro. Je me suis rendu
compte que
géopolitiquement
alors que le ministre Schubble voulait
que la Grèce sorte les Angela Merkel a
s'est rendu compte que c'était la crise
syrienne et que
les réfugiés syriens quitteraient la
Turquie et viendrai en Europe. Et donc
il y avait une raison politique aussi de
maintenir la Grèce dans la zone euro. Et
quand j'ai relié tous ces points, je me
dis j'ai dit le Grexit ne se produira
pas et puis il y aura un effet domino
vers l'effondrement de la zone eure.
Même chose un an plus tard, les gens
étaient inquiets que à Davos en janvier
en février 2016, il y aurait un
atterrissage très dur de la Chine. Ça a
commencé en en août 2015 et ça s'est
aggravé en janvier-février 2016. Il y
avait une chute des marchés financiers.
Ah là là, la Chine va s'effondrer, tous
les marchés vont euh tomber de 20 % et
ça sera dû à l'atterrissage de la Chine.
Et tout le monde a devoir se voudrait ça
sera l'atterrissage dur de la Chine.
Est-ce que ça fera une répétition de la
crise financière ? Je dis non, la Chine
n'aura pas un atterrissage doux mais il
n'aura pas un atterrissage euh dur. Ça
sera chaotique mais bon on va tenter de
contrôler la crise. Ça sera pas une
nouvelle crise financière. Sur deux
événements majeurs au cours de la
dernière décennie alors que le consensus
était Grexit et effondrement de la zone
euro et effondrement de la Chine et
fonte de de l'économie européenne,
j'étais beaucoup plus optimiste que le
consensus. De plus, quand je parle des
des menaces dans mon euh livre, je parle
pas d'aliens qui viennent de Mars qui
vont prendre possession de la Terre. Je
parle pas d'astéroïdes qui vont taper
euh la planète. Je parle de menaces que
tout le monde connaît. Il y a eu des
centaines de livres sur le changement
climatique, sur la dépression
géopolitique, sur la pandémie, sur les
menaces financières, sur la
démondialisation. Toutes ces choses-là
sont raisonnablement évidentes. Ce que
je fais moi, c'est que je je relie les
liens. J'appelle ça des méga menace.
D'autres appellent ça des polycrises.
Euh l'IMF appelle ça un des calamités.
Il y a eu un rapport sur les risques
semblables en connectant tous ces points
que je décris. Les idées sont là. Moi,
je relis les points et je les considère
d'un point de vue économique. Quels sont
les coûtes de ces méga menaces et
comment chacun chacune de ces méga
menaces affecte les autres méga menaces
et comment elles sont reliées les unes
aux autres ? Mais je parle pas de
science-fiction, c'est pas de la
science-fiction du tout. Ce sont des
menaces sur lesquelles tout le monde est
d'accord qu'elles existent. Certains
disent que ça c'est plus risqué que
d'autres.
Certains disent que ça va ça va arriver
dans un avenir plus lointain. Certaines
solutions sont plus probables que
d'autres. On peut être en d'accord ou
pas d'accord sur l'étendue, mais
personne ne dit que ces méga menaces
n'existent pas. Toutes ces méga menaces
existent. À quel point c'est leur
gravité ? Comment on peut les adresser
avant qu'ils soient trop tard ? C'est la
seule question, mais ça c'est ça peut
être débattu.
Dernière question internet.
Que pens-t-il de la sission de
l'humanité entre l'hyperclasse et le
reste ? Un peu comme dans le film
Élyséum.
On a vu au cours des dernières décennies
un un accroissement
et d'inégalité entre ceux qui possèdent
et ceux qui ne possèdent rien, ceux qui
ont plus et ceux qui sont laissés sur le
bord de la route. C'est arrivé dans des
activités dans des économies très
évoluées, le monde anglo-saxon, mais
aussi dans les marchés émergents en
Chine et en Inde. Et la réaction contre
les démocraties libérales, ça vient de
ces accroissements, de ces inégalités
de fortune. C'est dangereux parce que
quand il y a trop d'inégalité, ça mène à
des violences sociales, à des guerres
civiles, parfois à des révolutions ou à
la montée au pouvoir des régimes
populistes extrémistes de gauche ou de
droite et qui ne peuvent même pas
réduire ces inégalités.
Je pense que ces divisions sont
dangereuses
et finalement mènent à de la violence
intérieure ou extérieure extrême. La
montée des inégalités est une des
menaces auxquelles il faut faire face.
Le problème malheureux, c'est que
d'ordinaire les politiques de taxation
des riches, de la redistribution de la
la richesse vers les pauvres
ne réduisent pas significativement les
inégalités. Historiquement, l'inégalité
est réduite lorsqu'il y a des
révolutions, des guerres, des famines et
des pestes.
C'est les seuls cas où même les riches
meurent ou perdent leur fortune. Ça ne
réduit pas automatiquement l'inégalité.
La question qu'il faut se poser, c'est
est-ce que les politiques suffisamment
progressistes pour réduire l'inégalité
avant que la violence ne réduise
l'inégalité ? Je ne suis pas sûr que
nous ayons la bonne réponse à cette
question.
Est-ce que l'évasion fiscale est une
méga menace ? N'y a-t-il pas un risque
de guerre civile ?
L'évasion fiscale en soi n'est pas une
méga menace, mais la taxe évasion,
l'évasion des des des impôts, c'est une
des principales raisons pour le la
montée de l'inégalité
en raison de l'immigration, en raison
des technologies innovantes
en raison des biaisses,
du savoir, mais parce que les élites ont
aussi des puissances économiques et
politiques. Ils changent les lois en
leur faveur. Le capital est plus mobile
que le travail. Le capital peut
s'évader vers des lieux offshore où on
ne n'impose pas le capital
et qui permet à des individus riches
d'éviter les impôts ou de faire ce qu'il
faut.
Donc oui, ça c'est un problème.
Je voudrais avoir trois livres qui ont
été importants dans votre vie.
Je ne suis pas un juif religieux, je
suis laïque.
Mais la Bible,
principalement l'Ancien Testament est un
grand livre.
Il y a beaucoup de
dans la Genèse qui parlent de l'histoire
des tragédies de l'humanité. Les gens
disent que il y a beaucoup de violence
de sexe, de comportement incestueux et
de drames humains. Mais il y a de la
morale. Il y a des valeurs morales. Et
quand on crée une nation, comment on
crée une meilleure humanité ? En tant
que laïque, je crois que les gens
peuvent trouver dans l'Ancien Testament
des choses qui valent la peine d'être
lues.
Deuxième, lorsque j'ai grandi, je lisais
beaucoup de littérature
principalement au lycée de la
littérature européenne, pas simplement
italienne ou allemande, mais même
française.
Toutes les grands romans de
de littérature française,
un de mes favoris c'était
Standal.
Le rouge et le noir, grand roman pas
simplement de d'amour et de passion,
mais aussi de la société, de la
politique et la combinaison entre la
société, l'individu, la politique, c'est
un classique de la compréhension de la
société, pas simplement du drame
individuel. Donc c'est un livre
fascinant. Il y a beaucoup de grands
autres romans, mais ça c'est le
principal qui m'a qui a eu un effet sur
moi.
Et quand j'étais jeune, avant de vouloir
devenir économiste, j'étais fasciné par
la psychologie, la psychanalyse
et j'ai lu un des premiers livres de
Zigmund Freud, l'interprétation des
rêves. Et chaque fois que je rêvais,
j'essayais de le noter, de l'analyser.
Avant de devenir économiste, j'ai pensé
devenir psychanalyste
et de Freud, j'ai commencé à lire les
livres et les travaux de l'école de
Francfort
comme Adorno, Oppenheimer, Herbert
Marcus
et un mélange de psychanalyse marxiste
et je suis devenu un pseudoxiste,
un un socialiste en grosse bagnole Mais
j'ai appris sur Kanes et je suis devenu
un économiste du courant mainstream. Je
suis devenu économiste par l'école de
Francfort, Sigmund Freud, Herbert Marcus
et Marx.
Et voilà, j'en suis arrivé à comprendre
les systèmes économiques de façon plus
classique.
Ma dernière question sera, c'est pas une
question en fait, c'est laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
J'enseigne les jeunes, elles me disent
étant donné toutes ces méga menaces,
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ? Me
demandent-il. Et je leur dis beaucoup de
choses. Bien sûr, s'occuper du
changement climatique, ça exige choix
collectifs, mais on peut faire des
petits sacrifices individuels pour
réduire notre empreinte carbone. C'est
pas facile, mais on peut le faire.
On peut pas attendre des gouvernements.
Nous, nous devons le faire aussi
individuellement. Il faut s'organiser
politiquement et socialement.
La société civile, pas simplement des
partis politiques. Vous devez être vous
engagé. Vous devez vous engager.
Deuxième chose, il faut étudier.
Vous assurer que vous ne deviendrez pas
obsolescent en raison de l'intelligence
artificielle. Vous devez vous former en
sciences, en ingénierie, en math, en
technologie,
mais aussi vous devez avoir des études
dans les arts humains, dans les dans les
sciences humaines. Bien lire, bien
écrire ses capacités, les soft skills,
ce qu'on dit en français aussi, les soft
skills. Vous n'aurez pas le même travail
dans la même industrie tout au long de
la vie comme c'était comme ça
précédemment. Vous devriez être
suffisamment souple pour changer
d'emploi, suffisamment souple pour
comprendre la technologie et avoir un
esprit critique qui vous permettra
de réussir et de vous développer plutôt
que devenir obsolescent. Et vous rendre
compte que la vie est un marathon, c'est
pas un sprint. Faut étudier l'art
à la fac, réapprendre,
reformer, vous former au long cours,
être curieux et dans vos investissements
aussi, dans vos décisions
d'investissement. Si vous faites du
training au jour le jour, si vous vous
amusez avec des bitcoins, vous allez
perdre votre chemise. Il faut investir
et économiser chaque jour, pas beaucoup
mais chaque année
épargne 15 % de votre revenu par parce
que votre sécurité sociale et vos fonds
de pension seront plus là quand vous
serez vieux.
Il y aura rien pour vous. Donc il faut
que vous capitalisiez. Il faut
diversifier vos portefeuilles
euh des actions américaines,
européennes, internationales
et vous n'allez pas faire 100 % par an
parce que personne ne le fait. Vous
allez faire 8 à 10 % mais le principe
des intérêts composés 8 % par an composé
ça veut dire beaucoup d'argent à long
terme. Et si vous travaillez dur, si
vous étudiez dur, si vous restreignez un
petit peu, si vous restez curieux, si
vous épargn et vous épargn
classique et pas spéculative tout le
temps, vous vous en sortirez bien.
La vie est un marathon, ce n'est pas un
sprint. Si vous le faites probablement
vous allez survivre, vous développer en
dépit des méga menaces, spécialement si
vous êtes engagé dans la société pour
que ce monde soit meilleur pour vous,
pour vos amis, pour votre famille, pour
vos enfants et pour vos frères humains.
Nuriel Roubini, merci infiniment d'être
venu nous voir.
Thank you very much for having today.
was a great pleasure.
[Musique]